regions means regions is about posing
the question sorry start again
asymptotes are about posing the question
what is sort of my guidelines sort of
like um lane markings if you like that I
have to obey I've got to stay between
them but regions is about where do I
actually have to be where do I have to
pass through okay so before I get to
Regents let's just do a little flaw
determine hey hey man if you don't screw
numbers you don't know what they are
live values okay
but I tell you that both of the numbers
are positive okay if I take the product
of those two numbers what do you know
about the product it will also be
positive there's no way either those
from donated okay in the same way if I
told you one's negative and ones
positive you know that you'll get a
negative right by the same logic if I'd
like three numbers and I said two of
them are positive and one is negative
you would know that the product is
negative okay now we're thinking about
numbers yeah the same works for
functions so let's think of a simple
example X plus 1 over X minus 1 X
okay actually do me a favor draw
yourself a set of axes underneath this
we're gonna keep going after this so now
we were talking about numbers before
right and I've got some division here
don't forget division multiplication
they've really the same operation just
in the right so if I look at this theory
I've got three functions here that make
up my function much like before we had
three numbers that made up the number we
were really interested in okay so I want
to think about the behavior of these
things now unfortunately sort of these
numbers don't just stay put they change
their variable X plus 1 will change as X
changes okay so I have to think about
these as they they pass through these
different states sometimes they're
positive sometimes they're negative okay
so get out another color and take these
three lines X + 1 X - 1 x + 2 and graph
them onto your plane just in light
pencil so x + 1 yeah yeah cuz it works
okay I don't have to make it beautiful
and then I think okay as I go from left
to right what's happening to these three
functions how they're changing what does
that mean for my um my why the whole
thing which is what I'm interested in
okay these three lines break up our
graph into different sections so I
missed okay so all well a left right
I've got three numbers
see how I did the plus or minus right I
have three numbers and they're all
negative right negative times negative
times negative is negative right so I
know over on the left hand side this is
where the graph will be okay that's the
region I've shaded now as I cross over
this border I've got negative negative
positive these two negatives will cancel
okay and I'll be left with a positive
note and in fact every time I cross the
border I just switch okay that's what we
mean by shading regions I apologize my
colors are not very clear but let's just
quickly finish yourself what can I do
with this okay you can already read off
the vertical asymptotes right I didn't
say there are six I'm about to work out
my asymptotes are there are no
asymptotes miss graph yet come to
anything to do
therefore I'm working out regions
different question okay stay with me
stay with me okay what are my vertical
asymptotes guys thank you so one is here
and negative two is over here
those are my asymptotes degree of the
top is one degree of the bottom is to
what kind of acetone you have I've got
my vertical ones already and I'm gonna
have horizontal ibly
horizontal horizontal where thank you
okay
I've got my lane markings okay which is
the asymptotes I've got the reasons I'm
gonna pass through that sort of all we
need almost as just a second one two
three
that won't say hot can you see once
you've got your asymptotes and you've
got the regions you're in there's
nowhere else this function can go
it's got no other choices okay you try
and do some Wiggly shapes right you're
like maybe this comes down here but it
won't make the other regions okay so
regions about is it I was working out
positives and negatives okay what do you
want to think about is these three bits
here now
one quick question suppose I change this
top one X plus 1 is your x squared plus
one how would that change the regions
that we graph kind of car factorize that
any good what would I do I draw the
problem okay now in fact short of
drawing the parabola I can do that in
there
I can forget about the problem see you
at this rate I'll go next - one write X
minus one which is down here
I got X plus 2 and X square plus 1 is
not just any problem it's it's positive
definite right it never touches the axis
it's always up here so how does that
affect the sign of my graph if it's
always positive it has no effect on the
side
so it would be up here but I don't
conduced ignore him okay
if he was negative I would have to put
him in just to watch out for it because
he slip everything okay what yeah he's
always positive so I could disregard